POSSIBLY AS AS BAD AS THE
MEDIA SAYS THEY ARE.
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE, ACTUALLY.
THEY PUSH IT, THEY PUSH IT.
THAT'S WHY SMOLLETT CHASED
HIS PATH.
THAT'S WHY PEOPLE ATTACK
TRUMP SUPPORTERS.
THAT'S WHY POLITICS IS NOW A
PERSONAL VENDETTA.
WE HAVE THE SOCCER PLAYER.
WHAT'S HER NAME?
RAPPEN NAY?
NO ONE KNOWS THE HELL WHO
SHE IS UNTIL SHE BECOMES.
THIS THEN SHE BECOMES A
PROTECTED CLASS.
SHE EXPANDS HER MEDIA
FOOTPRINT BY SCREAMING
INFANTILE.
THE SELF-CENTERED ATHLETE
COST THE SPORTS MONEY BUT
TRENDING BY BEING A SELFISH
GRANDSTANDER.
THIS IS THE SAME PROBLEM.
THE MEDIA MAKES IT TO SO
THAT PEOPLE THINK THIS MIGHT
HELP THEM OR MAKE THIS
EMOTIONALLY GRATIFYING THING
BY ATTACKING SOMEBODY BUT
YOU JUST LOOK LIKE A LOSER.
>> Katie: JESSE, ERIC TRUMP
IS NOT PRESSING CHARGES.
THE SECRET SERVICE ALSO TOOK
A LOOK AT WHO THIS PERSON IS
WE REPEATEDLY SEE THIS
HAPPENING NOW AND GETS
JUSTIFIED AS OKAY BECAUSE
THE PRESIDENT IS DESTROYING
THE COUNTRY SOMEHOW AND,
THEREFORE, THEY ARE
VALIDATED IN THEIR ACTIONS.
>> Jesse: RIGHT.
YOU KNOW, JUAN IS MAKING A
FACE.
BUT I CAME PREPARED WITH A
WHOLE LONG LIST OF VIOLENT
ATTACKS ON TRUMP SUPPORTERS
FOR THE LAST TWO AND A HALF
YEARS.
IT'S A VERY LONG LIST.
>> Greg: GO THROUGH EACH
ONE.
>> Jesse: FIRE BOMBING,
ATTACKS WITH CROWBARS.
ATTACKS THROUGH WINDOWS.
INCLUDING BURNING ANIMAL CAR
CUS AND
CAS AND
CARCAND
CARCASD
CARCASS AND LEAVING ON
SOMEONE'S STOOP.
I KNOW JUAN YOU CAN SAY
THERE IS OTHER THINGS FROM
THE RIGHT YOU CAN SAY THEY
HAVE DONE.
THE OVERWHELMING AMOUNT OF
VIOLENCE IS COMING FROM THE
LEFT.
IMAGINE IF THIS HAD BEEN